DCU had me really worried there for a
minute assault on our co2 say that I was
nervous going into this one is a bit of
an understatement I had some pretty
major issues with Justice League war and
I flat out hated son of Batman so even
though I knew going in that this was not
part of that same continuity that
they're now building based off the new
52 I was still just flat-out nervous
because I was afraid DC animated movies
just had lost their mojo altogether
what a relief for me because this movie
is a total blast now I do feel the need
to point out that the full title Batman
assault on Arkham is a little bit of a
misnomer because Batman himself he's not
the focus on this he's around and it's
certainly it's set in his world and it's
dealing with a lot of his rogues gallery
but he himself he's not the focus but
really it's only the title that plays a
little bit of this bait-and-switch
because once you're into the film itself
it's very clear very early on as to who
the actual heroes of this story are now
in this case I use the term heroes very
loosely so here's your basic set up
Amanda Waller is a government operative
involved in some very shady stuff now
when the Riddler gets caught and jailed
for about the 500th times it turns out
that he had in his possession something
that Amanda Waller needs back that
MacGuffin is now in the property vault
at Arkham Asylum so Amanda Waller
assembles the latest version of The
Suicide Squad which is made up of
various convicts and not nice people to
go in and get it back this particular
iteration of the Suicide Squad is made
up of Deadshot king shark black spider
Captain Boomerang killer frost
cagey beast and Harley Quinn through
some really nice minimal use of
exposition the film establishes very
early on that some of these guys have
been in the situation and made part of
the Suicide Squad before some of them
it's completely new and they're being
brought in on this on the firt for the
first time the ones who get the most
focus are Deadshot and Harley Quinn and
if I'm being completely honest black
spider and cagey beast there I kind of
throw always a little bit but the other
three get some really nice moments and
some really nice to mention to them so
overall it's pretty well-balanced
how large the team is and this thing is
just a rollercoaster of a movie right at
the beginning every single member of the
team gets their own little sort of
opening segment to show who they are
what they're about and I'll give you a
little bit of a sense of you know their
fighting style of what it is they kind
of bring to the proceedings as part of
this team
there is plenty of action in this thing
and like I said since they've all got
different fight styles and ways of going
about combat
it keeps the action scenes from becoming
boring even though there's quite a few
of them offering one coming right after
another but it never gets overloaded it
stays well paced and given that these
heroes are well to put it bluntly they
are not nice people things do get quite
a bit violent at times but the thing is
in this case because of the nature of
these characters and their criminal
backgrounds and everything else it makes
sense that things are gonna get a bit
bloodier and a bit Messier as opposed to
say son of Batman where it was
completely gratuitous and there wasn't
really a point to how violent in god
voice working this thing is top-notch
this is taking place in the same
universe as the Arkham series of video
games which means we get some old pros
coming back into the mix namely we get
Kevin Conroy as Batman and we get CCH
pounder as Amanda Waller now we do get a
couple of replacement voices for some
established characters and they're
effectively brought in to give
impersonations of the best-known
versions of these characters
specifically we get this with Harley
Quinn and the Joker I normally would
have considered it a spoiler to mention
the Joker but the thing set in Arkham
you know he's at least going to appear
and the thing is on paper I'm not a huge
fan of the idea of actually being
brought in basically just to do an
impression of the last person who did it
as opposed to having the freedom to do
their own thing but honestly if the
results are gonna be this good I will
take it and be very happy with it
me I got a hand it out to hynden walch
and Troy Baker who are doing spot-on
impersonations of the work done by
Arleen Sorkin and Mark Hamill is Harley
Quinn in the Joker they might as well be
the real deal
rest of the voice cast all solid work
like the only one that threw me off a
little bit was Nolan North Scott nee
penguin I could have done with that but
he hardly drank things down and it was a
cameo appearance at that which brings me
to the other thing which is that I
really
how batman's better-known robes gallery
is sort of sprinkled across the film
they never take it over it's never about
them but given that it's set in Arkham
which houses so many of these well-known
characters characters much better known
than any member of The Suicide Squad it
really would have felt like a missed
opportunity if we didn't at least see
them and I like the ones that we see I
like the way in which they're used for
their little appearances it just it
feels like oh yeah cool but again they
never take over the film and it stays
properly focused I really I just had a
ton of fun with this thing and the only
complaints I have they're really
nitpicks yes Amanda Waller loses some of
her ambiguity and she's a bit more
straight-up villain than she normally is
but honestly given the nature of this
particular story I'm not sure there was
a way around that there's also a
surprising amount of near nudity on the
part of both female members of the
Suicide Squad which I kind of could've
done without but what I will say is we
are at these given reasons for why these
things are happening granted their
flimsy reasons sometimes but it's a heck
of a lot more than we got if as far as
explanation goes compared to say for
instance Talia al Ghul's outfit in son
of Batman which defied all combat
practicality as well as the laws of
physics so coming out of this I am
honestly I'm just relieved it's just
such a load off my mind to know that DC
animated movies can still be good now
the continuity being set with the new
ones which is the next film we're gonna
get with the throne of Atlantis I'm
really nervous about that because that
continuity needs to get better and it
needs to get better soon but if I've got
to slog through those in order to get
gems like this I'll do it I'll complain
about it but I'll do it in the spirit of
the Suicide Squad who's your favorite
b-list comic book villain you know what
you don't even have to give a DC one I
personally I've always had a soft spot
for Spider Man's doppelganger so whoever
is your favorite b lister drop something
down in the comments let's talk about it
as for me I'll be back as soon as I get
my next fix